pour la première fois pascal a été
frappé au visage par un chroniqueur en
difficulté comment va-t-il réagir la
suite dans un instant on va voir la
deuxième partie de gilles verdez et de
pascal le grand frère
est ce que vous voulez voir la première
quand même au cas où la wii on va
regarder la première
alors on va alors s'il vous plaît parce
que pour qu'on se remette en tête la
première c'est parti à l'onu gilles
verdez est un chroniqueur difficile mais
quand est ce que le conseil de classe on
bouffe or il ne respecte rien ni
personne
[Musique]
jusqu'à présent personne n'a osé
affronter celui qui fait trembler les
plus grandes stars du paf
personne sauf lui parce qu'elle sautait
plus connu sous le nom du grand frère
s'il vous plaît toujours à ces bavards
qui vous envoie sa soeur havrais mais
pour quelle raison j'ai pas émis de
chaîner fils il est en colère on regarde
et on va commencer par ça rend ma
casquette sur la tête alors apparemment
tout le monde gueule technique attention
tout le monde suit pascal le grand frère
le petit frère plutôt la faute à de
l'humour je vois c'est bien c'est bien
l'école pour l'instant merci à trouver
thiam supra sommes parlé de tout ce qui
te dérange à la télévision et ailleurs
je t'écoute mais tous ne dérange à la
télé on te dérange autant de repas par
mois matériel moi qui le fais pas pour
toi moi et lui et lui par terre qui a
fait curieux candidats pays il est plus
rien mais la douleur morale au tunnel
tapis gueule même en photo démange fait
défaut c'est lui qui savait pas d'un
super slogan soyez bosso et grand c est
beau grand mais pas moi pour la première
fois
pascal a été frappé au visage par un
chroniqueur en difficulté comment
va-t-il réagir la suite dans un instant
alors la fuite
et bien sûr on va voir comment pascal a
réagi s'est bien passé avec lui
très bien ouais bah ça se voit à
regarder
précédemment dans sos gilles verdez a
besoin dead est un petit frère plutôt la
voie
bonjour ça va attends je suis pas ton
pote moi je te parle correctement ces
sujets complément merde pas compris
sujet verbe complément qu'à raison
valérie clampett benjamin castaldi à
dole a géré la lola anne n'a pas de
blague un bisou à ma famille voilà
gilles craque
pascal a enfin réussi à gagner sa
confiance se sont terminées par fait je
vois que de bien quand tu te sens pas
changé ma vie franchement je te remercie
c'est génial franchement c'est une école
comme jamais d'accord mais je suis un
homme en colère se rend très calme et je
cherchais calmer merci pascal a pour
gilles verdez cette rencontre avec
pascal a été une révélation
merci pascal franchement fait devenu zen
pas changer ma vie je suis un autre
homme
merci à tamedia grosse mallette on est à
gauche si c'est parce que ça car grosse
bouffe ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]